Привіт в ефірі 3 4 телеканали
програма Люди слова програма в якій
виступає виключно люди які
знають ціну слову і які тримають свої
слова І сьогодні у нас у гостях перший
заступник міністра освіти та науки
молоді та спорту Доктор філософських
наук професор член кореспондент
академії педагогічних наук Євген
Миколайович Сулейман привіт
та у студії працюють наші журналісти люди
слова люди, які своїм словом несуть
правду в маси сьогодні у студії
присутній Олександр розумний газета
Дніпро вечірній Ольга Бондарчук газета
Сьогодні
Ігор Гусаров Дніпропетровська агенція
журналістських розслідувань
Анфіса Букреєва вести придніпров'я
Максим Мірошниченко газета Комсомольська
правда Тетяна Гонченко сайт місто dp.ua
та Олександр Пугач місто ТБ
панове журналісти Дозвольте уявити
Чарівно провідну Ольгу полів
яка сьогодні працює студії та
сьогодні вона союзник наших журналістів та
вже Згідно з нашою традицією, будь ласка
Євгеній Миколайович Ваше право першого
слова ваше звернення до наших журналістів
будь ласка, не дуже приємно бути сьогодні
у студії 34 каналу Я готовий до розмови з
дніпропетровськими журналістами думаю що
це Зустріч має бути принаймні
з одного боку приємна з іншого
сторони нести той діловий ефект який
Кожен з нас чекає щодня на своїй
роботі дякую Тема нашої сьогоднішньої
програми наскільки цінні сьогодні вища
освіта та Наскільки часто випускники
працюють Відповідно до обраної
спеціальності та здобутим знанням Отже
хто готовий поставити перше запитання
будь ласка Ігор Гусаров
Дніпропетровська агенція журналістських
розслідувань
Ігор Миколайович У нас велике
Виробнича область та наше
виробничники просто плачуть і
скаржаться на відсутність кваліфікованих
кадрів технічних спеціальностей Усі
хочуть бути юристами економістами
рекламниками не знаю чим ще Як ви
вважаєте ринок праці здатний сам себе
регулювати або додаткові
фактори його регулювання Ззовні Я думаю
що ви правильно сказали що ринок праці
повинен сам себе регулювати коли
станеться перенасичення воно вже сьогодні
про себе говорить ті самі фахівці
юристи економісти просто будуть
перекваліфікуватися йти на друге
освіта тому що чи немає
роботи яку вони можуть знайти або ж
вони відчують що може бути
дійсно є щось більше
цікаве ніж те, що вони отримали Я
згоден з тим, що держава не повинна
стояти осторонь тому я хочу помітити
що протягом двох років
Міністерство освіти коригує
державне замовлення з боку
держави на збільшення
державних місць на науці які
більше відносяться до технічних
інженерним природничим наукам з іншого
сторони ми прогнозуємо їх збільшення
завтра в день І тим самим ми хочемо таким
чином стимулювати і тих хлопців
які хочуть присвятити себе саме цим
спеціальностям Спасибі Євген
Миколайович Максим Мірошниченко газета
Комсомольська правда Скажіть будь ласка
зараз дуже багато рейтингів ВНЗ ось
випускників школи приходить в один
університет йому там кажуть
Університет допустимо на шостому місці він
приходить до іншого ВНЗ інший ВНЗ говорить
що ні вони на шостому місці є
якийсь один рейтинг Ну офіційний
скажімо так і як на ці рейтинги впливає
саме Міністерство освіти Ну
по-перше я дуже радий, що вас теж уже
порушує це питання з рейтингами чесно
кажучи чуючи коли кажуть що потрібно все
віддати на відкуп рейтингу я вам хочу
відразу помітити що кожен рейтинги в
основі своїй мають свої основні
основні показники тобто вони
практично профільні якщо у нас
рейтинг який робиться під егідою
назва компас це насамперед Який
орієнтують більше на випускників де
як працевлаштувалися випускники тих чи
інших вищих навчальних закладів саме
головне тут критерій це
працевлаштування випускників, звичайно ж
тут краще підходити не просто як ви
знаєте лінива людина відкрила рейтинг і
відразу все зрозумів краще все-таки пошукати
спробувати Як попрацювати з
енциклопедією Дякуємо Євгеній Миколайович
та чергове питання будь ласка Анфіса
Букреєва вести передньопров'я Скажіть
будь ласка, а що заважає нашим
університет там увійти до числа
університетів світового класу я можу
сказати тільки одне ми не вміємо ще
працювати так щоб потрапляти такі
рейтинги Про що йдеться Якщо хтось
думає що так просто десь хтось на
ринку здає своє місце не вірте цьому та
сьогодні тільки тупий має не розуміти
що рейтинги які складаються в
всьому світі є орієнтиром раніше
всього у конкуренції на ринку
освітніх послуг ніколи не будуть
здавати свої позиції доводитимуть
що в Україні погана освіта
в Україні недостатньо гарною
кваліфіковані фахівці викладають
і так далі так далі так далі але в те
ж саме час вони стоять у черзі за
нашими магістрами за нашими аспірантами
за нашими кандидатами наук які
володіють англійською мовою і яких тут
ж на корені відразу ж запрошують забирають
в університети всього світу які
показують дуже добрі результати
Дякую будь ласка Господа журналісти
ваші питання Тетяна гонченко сайт
місті Україні лише 15-20 відсотків
випускників ВНЗ йдуть Працювати за
спеціальності Як ви думаєте чому
така складна ситуація взагалі Чи потрібно
така освіта якщо людина все одно
потім не користується цими знаннями
людина дійсно зібралася пішла
вчитися віддавав усі знання час
старання але вийшовши з університету з
такої спеціальності розуміє, що сьогодні
Держава та роботодавцям це не потрібно
Тут дуже багато факторів і сказати що
причина тільки в одному, що наші ВНЗ
погано когось готують Я б так сто
відсотків не говорив Дякую в
продовженні цієї теми хотілося б
запропонувати невелике соціальне опитування
наші журналісти провели в одному з ВНЗ
міста Дніпропетровська питання для всіх
студентів був один збираєтеся ви в
надалі Працювати за фахом
увага на екран
збираюся працювати за своєю
спеціальності тому що треба зробити
цей світ Краще хоч комусь і
тому треба зробити це мені я так
вважаю і ми освіту мені в цьому
допоможе звичайно планую Навіщо я тоді
вступала на свою спеціальність за
спеціальності Швидше за все немає ну я
має намір Працювати за спеціальністю ось
Якщо все складеться успішно магістратура
аспірантура ось мені звичайно цього
хотілося б та зараз працюю в цьому
напрямку
ні не збираюся Працювати по
спеціальності
це спеціально щоб Працювати по
спеціальності в нашій країні На жаль
спеціальність не котирується та вважається
що людина яка навчає молодь
майбутнє дає нашій нації він повинен
отримувати мало грошей та я збираюся
Працювати за фахом німецької
мови зі знанням які можу тут
отримати я можу вибрати щось більше
цікаве для мене дуже важливо щоб
твоя професія була твоя, щоб ти завжди
йшов із великим ось інтересом Щоб тебе
завжди щось надихало єдиний
варіант який зараз бачу
тому що інших варіантів якби були
Я вступив би на інший факультет для
моєї спеціальності я абсолютно не бачу
ніяких перспектив тобто для моїх
планів до чого там хочу собі життя я не
бачу в цій країні принаймні
точно Так збираюся
звичайно але якщо зараз знаю що зараз
затребувані та інші спеціальності
тому можливо я хочу захочу отримати
та друга освіта є якісь курси
Я не думаю що моя майбутня спеціальність
допоможе змінити світ на краще
принаймні а-а на даний момент це
те що мене цікавить і те до чого мене
лежить душа
ось така думка студентів
опитування провели перед будівлею
Дніпропетровського національного
університету імені Олеся Гончара та
зараз Я хочу запросити студію нашого
другого гостя ректора Дніпропетровського
національного університету імені Олеся
Гончара доктора фізико-математичних
наук професора заслуженого діяча
науки та техніки України Микола
Вікторовича Полякова Здрастуйте
Микола Вікторович Привіт
Будь ласка займайте ваше місце у нашій
студії Дякую що прийшли щойно ви
таємній кімнаті бачили все, що відбувається
тут у нашій студії І як ви можете
прокоментувати думку студентів
які навчаються саме в університеті
очолюєте які ви знаєте Ну перше
звичайно деякі питання відповіді як
вектори мене безперечно порадували А ось
деякі відповіді теж зрозумілі, але вони не
дуже порадували мене як ректора навіщо
було надходити
Це неправильно це не модно Дякую
Чи існує якась статистика щодо
результатам здобуття вищої
освіти скільки студентів йдуть
Працювати за фахом І скільки
студентів, які закінчили ВНЗ, не йдуть
працювати за отриманою спеціальністю
отже статистика наступна близько 80
відсотків таки йдуть за фахом
пацієнтів 12-15 вони працюють не по
спеціальності Отже Господа журналісти
будь ласка ваші запитання Олександр
розумний газета Дніпро вечірній
будь ласка, вказуйте кому питання
є така статистика що ось в Україні
е-е
9.000 ВНЗ А в Іспанії де приблизно
стільки ж населення 60 університетів
вам не здається що така кількість
вищих навчальних закладів в Україні не
народжує нової якості Чи буде вже
виснажені заходи там ліцензуванням може
бути або скорочення провести дякую ну
я хотів у вас заспокоїти в Україні 841
вищий навчальний
вищий навчальний заклад тобто
давайте ми будемо цією цифрою оперувати
і тоді не так все страшно буде це
перша частина друга я не прихильник ось
безпосередньо як Вибачте мені перший
заступник міністра силових методів
посилення Я вважаю що повинні бути
рівні умови, які повинні виконувати
тільки ті, які можуть їх виконати
якщо вони не можуть їх виконувати Вибачте
мене Значить виходить ви не отримуєте
або ліцензію на ту чи іншу
спеціальність чи не акредитуєтеся
цьому мають бути державні
стандарти державні критерії та
державні вимоги до системи
освіти я взагалі хотів би сказати
що це може бути навіть питання
національної безпеки будь ласка
Ольга Бондарчук газета Сьогодні питання
Євгеній Миколайовичу минулого року було
рекордно Мала кількість випускників
шкіл і державне замовлення довелося урізати майже
удвічі в майбутньому чи збільшуватиметься
замовлення бюджетні місця тому що на носі
підростає покоління бобі-буму потрібно
якось десь вчитися можете бути
адже спокійні Міністерство економіки
яка доводить насамперед проект
державного замовлення надає
його на розгляд уряду
ґрунтується саме на ось цих
показниках демографічних
економічних вивчення ринку потреби
на ринку праці тих чи інших фахівців
і коли таке рішення ухвалюється воно
ґрунтується тільки на об'єктивних
тому силу того що
минулого року було менше випускників
менше замовлення я вам хочу сказати що в
цього року замовлення було більше Микола
Вікторович хочу перевірити одразу на місці
слова заступника міністра ваше замовлення цього року
близько 500 480 у нас плюс ось навіть
замовлення
хороша тенденція будь ласка Олександр
Пугач місто ТБ Раніше у студентів було
дві сесії а зараз напевно вже у всіх
ВНЗ чотири сесії як це вплинуло на
ефективність їх успішності
система яка сьогодні вона означає
передбачає навчання все-таки
регулярне навчання Ось це в кінці
кінців і менше стало відрахувань по
з цього приводу ось так що це система
яка стимулює постійну роботу
нам здається більш прогресивною та потрібною
та корисною для студента очікуються
якісь зміни ось система
навчанню вже всередині ВНЗ тому що
все-таки досить Революційна ось то
що є зараз я хочу вам сказати що
ми задали напрямок головне гасло
який написаний на нашому Міністерстві на
словах міністра завжди проповідує наш
це якість освіти більше за нас
нічого не цікавить будуть якісні
знання це чудово як
знання будуть виключно Якщо є
бажання опановувати ці знання Якщо
студент прийшов усвідомлено на усвідомлено
обрану спеціальність і він опановує
цими знаннями
чергове невелике соцопитування
провели наші журналісти був достатньо
пізнавальним і повчальним щоб
питання звучало Так навіщо вам вища
освіта і знову ж таки студенти міста
Дніпропетровська абсолютно відверто
відповіли на це важливе питання
на екран
вища освіта для мене це вже
означає якась зумовленість це
вже рішучість вища освіта Мені
необхідно для того, щоб просуватися
далі по життю самореалізуватися та бути
повноцінним осередком суспільства щоб бути
освіченим щоб мати якийсь статус
з вищою освітою я зможу влаштуватися
на хорошу роботу і надалі просуватися
по життю Щоб було щоб
скористатися не в майбутньому щоб
успішно влаштувати життя своє насправді
справі я навчаюсь в Університеті для того
щоб я думаю що мені цей університет
дасть якусь професію там дорогу
кудись там
мови і мені це подобається і як би я
вважаю це можливість
Можливо десь там кудись поїхати
що-небудь і якось там вже тут я
не бачу
для того, щоб продовжити і нормально
жити у цій країні заробляти
нормальні гроші звичайно щоб працювати
за своєю спеціальністю
або у школі чи університеті
хочу здобути вищу освіту щоб
вдосконалюватися в тій галузі ось
знань, які я обрала в даному випадку
фіологія ось так хочеться стати справжнім
майстром слова Ну що отримати хорошу
роботу далі працювати забезпечувати свою
сім'ю Ну якось тобто забезпечити собі
майбутня вища освіта що це
просто папірець якого вона є
молодець Червоний папірець ще краще але
ти такий знаєте як поштовх життя
піднімає вгору, бо далі є
крила ти можеш злетіти А без цього
це можна з метафора провести оперення
а ось така ось думка студентів У
кожного свою думку часто Вони
збігаються але є і діаметрально
протилежне питання до вас Євген
Миколайович Скажіть, чи не спостерігається
якась девальвація вищої освіти
зі збільшенням кількості ВНЗ у
Україні Якщо є попит на ринку, значить
має бути пропозиція це перша частина
друга частина що якість має
відповідати тим вимогам які
пред'являються до цієї якості сьогодні
найголовніше що на ринку праці приходячи
як у магазин товар у вигляді студента
випускників є
підставою для того, щоб його хтось
купив чи ні не по диплому упізнанням
Микола Вікторович хоче доповнити Ви
знаєте, я повністю підтримує слова
Миколайовича справді беруть людей
зараз уже слава Богу поменшало таких
які телефонними чи якимись правом
користувалися знанням Спасибі Микола
Вікторович, звичайно ж
це перш за все ВНЗ потрібно йти
усвідомлено здобувати спеціальність і потім
вже отримувати дивіденди від свого
навчання саме так будь ласка Господа
журналісти ваші запитання Тетяна Гонченко
сайт місті.ua просто Євгенія Миколайович
наскільки мені відомо Міністерство
розглядає варіант щоб навчальний рік
у студентів починався не 1 вересня 1
жовтня нібито щоб вони встигли відпочити
у Криму Чи справді так є і
чи можливо що вже наступного року
студент у студентів буде довшим
канікул наскільки я пам'ятаю міністр
освіти науки молоді та спорту
перебуваючи у відрядженні у Криму
на запитання, яке було йому поставлено А ​​не можна
чи зробити так, щоб у нас цілодобово
цілий рік були туристи і раніше
всього молодь
відповів так як ви сказали
сьогодні я не готовий відповісти на
це питання серйозніше, ніж оскільки
відповів міністр Дякую будь ласка Ігор
Гусарів агентство журналістських
розслідувань
зараз згадали радянську систему
освіти у зв'язку з цим питання
Скажіть будь ласка, а ось Які гарні
тенденції корисні тенденція цієї
системи ми зараз втратили і що
хорошого привели натомість я вам чесно
хочу сказати ми наукою більше займалися
той час у Радянське тому що я так
розумію що у нас були наукові товариства
які стимулювалися поїздками
поїздками за кордон на конференцію Я
таки закликаю як заступник міністра
який загалом допомагає визначати
політику в цьому питанні що ось це
автономія вищого навчального закладу не
тільки в тому, щоб поділити гроші але
ще й м'яко кажучи розвиватися та
планувати себе так, щоб було
поповнення та наукових кадрів та
талановитих молодих людей, які прийдуть
вас пірантуру щоб завтра того рейтингу
ж самого ви один заклад обов'язково
зростання Микола Вікторович Ви згодні з
цими гіркими словами є інші
можливості у сьогоднішніх студентів і ті
які цінують Ось вони дійсно
прийшли до університету отримати ці знання
і бути корисними суспільства не прийшли так
побалакати так прогулятися там 8 початок
85 вже заняття закінчилися їсти інші
справи Микола Вікторович У мене до вас
буде прохання ось не проводити особисті
бесіди з тими студентами, які нам
давали інтерв'ю, бо студенти
народ чесні і ми їм дуже вдячні
за них сприймаю як колег я навпаки
прошу приходити і Давайте поговоримо Я
адже від них багато чого доброго та
корисного візьмуть для нашої спільної справи
будь ласка Анфіса Букреєва вести
предметів Євгеній Миколайович скажіть ось
корупція вона не на останньому місці в
числі проблем вищої освіти
України принаймні це кажуть
студенти та їхні батьки якісь
корупційні дії проводяться
Міністерством звинувачуючи систему
освіти в корумпованості Я б
хотів щоб нас не плутали із системою МВС
ми не повинні займатися тим, щоб
хапати когось за руку ті, хто погано
вчиться не бачать іншого варіанта Як
зробити пропозицію викладачеві
закрити на його незнання таким чином
ось я хочу ще додати пропонують ці
гроші ті хто не
вчить він свідомо не вчить Авось
Викладач не встоїть і добре один із
питань, які ми задали студентам
нашого національного університету та
мінялися Гончара це стануть вам у нагоді
надалі отримані вами знання
давайте послухаємо і подивимося що думає
сьогодні студенти будь ласка увагу на
екран
ті знання, які я отримаю дуже мені
стануть у нагоді в житті
і роботі звичайно це знадобиться по
роботі Я вивчаю іноземні мови
тому я можу далі шукати себе і
знаходити в різних варіантах життя
трохи підучитися і надалі
знадобилися ці знання в університеті або
у школі дітям яким я буду
розповідати так я вважаю що вони дуже
стануть у пригоді і мій факультет дійсно
дає ті знання, які мені будуть
необхідні надалі кожна людина
бере те чого йому потрібно та те, що йому
необхідно Я тут беру те, що мені потрібно
і як би Сподіваюся я зможу ці знання
застосувати своєю професією Так я
збираюся застосувати у повному повному
серйозно повному сенсі повному обсязі
цього всього правильно говориться що ми
тільки якийсь відсоток ціна не отримуємо
університеті тобто там відсотків 80
треба робити самому Даню мені вже потрібно
Чому припустимо за столом можна щось
обговорити мені пощастило тому що навчаюсь у
мене там, де я хотіла
освіта це вже те, що тебе
характеризує як професіонала але
знання вони знадобляться у будь-якому випадку
якщо вони є як би без хліба не
залишишся
ось така думка студентів
університету і звичайно ж кожен
приходить ВНЗ той отримує саме те на
що він розраховує звичайно ці знання
стануть у пригоді я думаю тут навіть
коментувати нічого не треба Господа
журналісти залишилося часу зовсім
трохи будь ласка бліц- питання
будь ласка, Олександр Пугач місто ТБ
Скажіть студенти бюджетних місць вони
повинні відпрацьовувати обов'язково після
установах немає
будь ласка Ольга Бондарчук газета
Сьогодні Скажіть будь ласка За якими
критеріям видають ліцензії ВНЗ
акредитацію Чому так буває що ВНЗ
працює 10-15 років, а потім його закривають
та студентів у дипломи студентів
анулюється я так думаю ви перш за все
Говоріть напевно про приватну вищу
навчальному закладі він просто не
витримує конкуренцію і коли до нього
приїжджають для того, щоб в черговий раз
Він підтвердив пройшов акредитацію то
виявляється, що у нього невідповідність
кадрового
потенціалу Тобто він не може сьогодні
за рахунок своїх студентів забезпечити
доктора професора наук у тому числі
яке необхідне для тієї чи іншої
спеціальності Після цього у нього
виявляється що він при зрізі з боку
інспекції студенти показують низькі
знання Виходячи з цього іржав на комісія
приймає рішення про анулювання або
непроходження акредитації що саме
собою витягне закриття цієї вищої
навчального закладу Дякую Тетяна
гонченкова сайт місті.ua зараз
абітурієнти мають право подавати
документи відразу в три ВНЗ на кілька
спеціальностей в результаті виходить
Безладдя тому що негози не можуть
зрозуміти хто куди хоче вчинити це в
п'ять вище навчальних закладів на три
спеціальності чи не потрібно скоротити
кількість щоб людина відразу
визначився куди він хоче ким якби
ось ми з вами Так от логічно всі
подумали то можливо ми таке рішення
Але ось я бачу навіть поряд з вами
по-моєму, колега він не згоден.
мама майбутнього абітурієнта категорично
проти
має розуміти бути у вас поняття що
ось ця відповідь на це питання носить вже
майже політичний характер тому що
завтра звинуватить міністрів у тому, що він
утискає права Чому торік
можна було, а нам цього року ні виходять
люди починають піднімати плакати
розповідають що потрібно якогось цапа
водити навколо робота будівлі і ось на
Елементарна політика будується
Тому чесно кажучи і цього року я
рекомендуватиму для прийняття рішення
міністру залишити так само, як це
було і в цьому, і в минулому, і позаминулому
році Дякуємо вам абітурієнти ви їх
батьки ось від душі Хоча мені здається
все-таки напрямок потрібно знати чітко
ви правильно все говорите має бути
чітке розуміння Чого хоче дитина
коли у нас сьогодні й батьки не знають
чого вони хочуть Тому краще Нехай 5 А
там де 5 там і сім а там де 7 там і
10 Дякую Господа журналісти Я
дякую нашим гостям Я сподіваюся що
деякі міфи про вищу освіту
сьогодні розвіяли та почули
відверті та компетентні відповіді від
Першого заступника Міністра Освіти
та Науки молоді та спорту доктора наук
професора члена кореспондента академії
педагогічних наук Євгена Миколайовича
суліми Дякуємо Вам та від ректора
дніпропетровської національної
університету імені Олеся Гончара, доктора
фізика математичних наук професора
заслуженого діяча науки та техніки
Миколи Вікторовича Полякова Ми
дякуємо нашим гостям Я дякую
журналістів і сподіваюся, що нашим глядачам
було цікаво і вже традиційно наприкінці
нашої програми будь ласка Шановні
гості ваше слово нашим людям слово тим
які несуть правду в маси до наших
журналістам Євгеній Миколайович
будь ласка Ваше право перше слово я
хотів би звернутися до вас насамперед до
людям, які найчастіше беруть інтерв'ю
або ж узагальнюють інформацію про ту чи
іншій проблемі велике прохання ретельніше
розберіться у цьому питанні Запитайте
компетентних людей і тоді ваша
Інформація буде безцінною Микола
Вікторович будь ласка, щоб обговорювати
проблеми які є у цій справі потрібно
знати про що питати ось сьогодні слава
Богові відчувалася і увага і так
компетентність У сенсі професіоналізму
Я хотів би щоб ваші діти
запозичили у вашому чудову професію
Я хотів би всім нам побажати добра
Дякую це була програма Люди слово в
якою ми розвіюємо міфи і звичайно ж
несемо Слово честі глядачеві До побачення
далі буде